サッバパッパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ サチッッタパリオダパナン エタングブッダンササナナン
ナモタッサバーガヴァト アラハト サッマ サムブッダッサ ナモタッサバーガヴァト アラハト サッマ サムブッダッサ
ナモタッサバーガヴァト アラハト サッマ サムブッダッサ
ブッダン サラナン ガッチャミ
ダンマン サラナン ガッチャミ
サンガム サラナン ガッチャミ
ドゥティアンピ ブッダン サラナン ガッチャミ
ドゥティアンピ ダンマン サラナン ガッチャミ
ドゥティアンピ サンガム サラナン ガッチャミ
タティアンピ ブッダン サラナン ガッチャミ
タティアンピ ダンマン サラナン ガッチャミ
タティアンピ サンガム サラナン ガッチャミ
タナティパタ ヴェーラマニ シッカパダン サマディヤミ
アビンナ ダナ ヴェーラマニ シッカパダン サマディヤミ
カーメス ミンチャチャラ ヴェーラマニ シッカパダン サマディヤミ
ムサワダ ヴェーラマニ シッカパダン サマディヤミ
シュラーミーラヤ マンジャパ マダッターナ ヴェーラマニ シッカパダン サマディヤミ
はい 次懺悔をいたします
無始なる過去から今まで
私たちは無明のせいで
無知のせいで 貪瞋痴のせいにせいで心が汚れて
無数の過ちを犯しました
この体の行為の過ち 言葉の過ち
思考の過ちを無数に行いました
それから 聖なる聖者たちにも
いろいろ無礼な侮辱の言葉を
態度を取ったり 言葉を喋ったり
数々の過ち 過ちを犯してきました
今世においても 我々は犯した過ちの数がキリがありません
この全ての過ちを仏法僧の前で
涅槃解脱に達する目的で
心を清らかにする目的で
心込めて懺悔いたします
仏法僧のお許しがありますように
慈悲の瞑想いたしましょう
私は幸せでありますように
私の悩み 苦しみがなくなりますように
私の願いごとが叶えられますように
私に悟りの光が現れますように
私は幸せでありますように
ここで一旦ビデオを止めて
二分ぐらい私は幸せでありますようにと繰り返し念じてください
私の親しい生命が幸せでありますように
私の親しい生命の悩み
苦しみがなくなりますように
私の親しい生命の願いごとが叶えられますように
私の親しい生命にも悟りの光が現れますように
私の親しい生命が幸せでありますように
ここで一旦ビデオを止めて 「
私の親しい生命が幸せでありますように」と二本程度繰り返し念じてください
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
生きとし生けるものの悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
生きとし生けるものの願いごとが叶えられますように
生きとし生けるものにも悟りの光が現れますように
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
ここでビデオを止めて
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますようにと
二分程度繰り返し念じてください
私の嫌いな生命が幸せでありますように
私の嫌いな生命の悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
私の嫌いな生命の願い事が叶えられますように
私の嫌いな生命にも悟りの光が現れますように
私を嫌っている生命が幸せでありますように
私を嫌っている生命の悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
私を嫌っている生命の願い事が叶えられますように
私を嫌っている生命にも悟りの光が現れますように
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
はい 慈悲の瞑想終わります
ありがとうございます
えっと それから今日はあの慈悲の瞑想のあの説明を特にしていただかなかったんですけど
あのやっぱり慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー瞑想は一体でやった方がいいというか
あの誤解を受けて 慈悲の瞑想をして
この心と体を清めるんです
いわゆるあの悪に染めている本人が体を清めるんです
この場合 肉体の清めるではなくて
あの 何と言いますか この心の清めなんですね
だから清め 清らかな人が修行を始めるという
最初からもうクリーン状態で始めなくちゃいけない
手術する前に完全にクリーンな状態で始まるでしょ
そういうことで 手術は大事ですけど
そのまま手術しないんですね
あらゆる方法でまずクリーンするんですね
そういう風に あの 最初に戒律を守って戒律を唱えて
それから慈悲の瞑想して
完全なクリーン状態になって
無菌状態になってからヴィパッサナーに入るんです
はい これから皆様に一人一人で実践できるようにと
できるようにと ヴィパッサナー瞑想の仕方を詳しく説明していきます
ヴィパッサナー瞑想を実践する方々に
我々はずっと言っていることが
絶えず限りなく常に実況中継してくださいという言葉です
ですから ヴィパッサナー瞑想イコール実況中継であると思ってください
まず 次になぜ実況中継が瞑想でしょうかっていうことについて
ほんの少々説明していきます
これは理解していただかないと瞑想は進まない可能性があります
私たちには目 耳 鼻 舌 体
それから心という六つの認識チャネルがあります
仏教用語で眼耳鼻舌身意と言うんですね
この眼耳鼻舌身意で我々は色声香味触法というデータを感じているんです
目に入るのは色というんですね
色と形と理解してください
耳に入るのは空気の振動
音なんですね で 鼻に入るのは香りとか匂いですね
舌に触れるのは味ですね
体には硬さと熱を触れるんです
心にはもうその他すべてのものは心に触れるんですね
というか 心に触れるものは様々なものだから
我々は法と言うんです
そこで問題は 目に色と形しか触れないのに
我々は頭の中で 心の中で
それは画像化するんです
この私の頭の中で作る画像と
他人の頭の中に作る画像がぴったし同じという保証はありません
どんな画像が他人が作るのかとわからないんですね
それから私の脳みそで作った画像を
私は自分の感情を入れて解釈するんですね
説明するんです 理解するんです
それからストーリーを作って作って記憶に残るんです
ですから 我々の記憶にあるのは決して現実ではないんです
自分の脳の中で 仏教的に言えば心の中で作った幻覚なんですね
このプログラムに我々は捏造という風に言うんですね
パーリ語でパパンチャという言葉を使っているんですね
それで耳に触れるのは空気の振動だけです
それで自意識といって
心でそれは心でそれは確認するんです
それから その確認したことを理解できる音に
頭の中で心の中で解説するんです
それから過去の感情やら好みやら
いろんなものを混ぜてストーリーを作るんです
このストーリーを記憶として心に溜めておくんです
それも捏造なんです それで舌に触れるのはただの苦味
甘みなどなどの仏教的には 7種類というんですけど
日本では 6種類かな  5種類かな
味なんですね それが我々は心の中で美味しい
まずい 気に入りなどなどの捏造してから理解するんです
で そういうふうに体に触れるのは硬さと熱だけ
しかし 私たちにはもう机を触ったり
テーブルを触ったりするんですね
本を取ったりするんです
それはありえないんです
手で本はわからないんです
手がわかるのは硬さと熱だけなんです
そこで頭の中で捏造するんですね
本を 本は捏造ではないと思うかもしれませんけど
捏造です なぜならば 猫ちゃんにも本を触ることはできます
しかし 猫さんの脳みその中で本だという概念は生まれません
そういうわけだから 五根から入る情報を我々はストーリー作って捏造して記憶として
これが事実であると記憶にしておくんですね
ですから 我々は自分が作った幻覚の世界で生きているんですね
世界は知らないんですね
この捏造の仕組みを破ることがヴィパッサナー瞑想の目的の一つなんですね
ですから 私はあなたのことを知ってますよと言ったっても
私はあなたのことは知りません
私はあなたについて何を妄想しているのかと知ってますということなんですね
そうすると 私はあなたのことを知ってますよとこれこれやと言ったっても
相手が嫌な気持ちになったり
違いますよと言ったり
は思ったりはするんですね
だからこの世の中でなかなかコミュニケーションなんかは成り立ってはいないんですね
それでなんで我々の心が汚れるのかというと
それはこの心の中にある捏造プログラムの結果なんです
空気の振動は心は汚せません
光と色は心は汚しません
そんな気持ちは全くないです
咲く花には人の心を汚してしまいたいという気持ちは全くないんです
自分で汚すんです 自分が汚れるんです
それは捏造するからなんですね
だから花を見て欲で心を汚すこともできるし
怒りで心を汚すこともできるし
落ち込みで心を汚すこともできるし
何でもできるんです 何か味わって
怒りで心を汚すこともできるし
欲で心を汚すこともできるし
だから心を汚すのはこの捏造システムなんです
それで清らかな心を作りたいと思うならば
我々はこの捏造する過程
それを理解してストップする訓練しなくちゃいけないんですね
それ全てまとめて 私はわかりやすくするために
ヴィパッサナー瞑想する方々は一切思考をやめましょうと言うんですね
で 思考をやめた方が楽なんです
これ無理ですよ 思考をやめることは
それで思考というのは
捏造したデータをさらにかけまして
さらにかけまして 新しい新しい概念
新しい捏造概念を作りまくることなんですね
例えば 目から何か入った情報で欲が作ったならば
それについて思考妄想して
どんどんどんどん欲を増やしていくんですね
怒りが生まれたら どんどん心の中で怒りを拡大して膨張させて持っていくことはできます
自己破壊するまで だから我々はなんか歩く原子炉を壊れた原子炉みたいなもんで
かなり危険なんですね
心のシステムが ですから
この修行のスタートは
私はじゃあ思考をすべてやめてみましょうと
と言っても 思考をやめることは論理的に無理なんですね
なぜならば 光の速度よりは 17倍程度の速さで
もっと速さで心が回転するんです
ですから思考するんですね
妄想するんです だから提案するのは実況中継しましょうと
実況中継すると心が忙しくなるんです
他の思考妄想する暇がなくなるんですね
それで実況中継は日本文化から作った単語で
パーリ語でお釈迦様がおっしゃったことは
今の瞬間に気づいていることなんですね
気づきですね パーリ語でサティと言うんですね
だから気づきといったら
なんかどういうふうに気づくのか
ちょっとわからなくなりますから
より具体的にわかり やすく
実況中継しましょうということにしているんですね
そこで思考をやめたらやばいと思う方々はいるかもしれません
でも人々は思考する能力を持っていないんですよ
ですから やばくないんです
人々の思考を見ると それがやばいんですよ
なぜならば 結局は妄想しているんだから
そこで正しい思考は 瞑想をうまく上手にできた方々にだけ正しい思考できるんです
論理的に 具体的に 人の役に立つ
自分の幸福になる 人の幸福になる
素晴らしい清らかな思考は
瞑想のできた人に 瞑想の達人たちにできますので
思考は完全に死んでしまうことではありませんので
心配しないでください
とにかく我々の思考をまとめて
ちょっと否定的な言葉を使うんです
あえて妄想 妄想をやめましょうと
そのために妄想をやめるために
これからいくつかの訓練を教えていきます
では 実況中継っていうのは
今の瞬間で自分がやっていることを実況することなんですね
例えば 今の瞬間で手を挙げているんだったら
上げる上げると実況する
手を下げているんだったら下げる下げるって実況する
手を伸ばしてボールペンを取っているならば
伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす 取る
取る 取る 運ぶ 運ぶと実況すればいいのです
そうやって今やっていることを実況することだけなんですね
だから我々にとっては
この今何をやっているかということ
ややこしくてちょっと難しくなっているんですね
だからこれは切って切って極力シンプルにしなくちゃいけないんですね
まず 私はいくつかのレッスンというタイトルであの基本的なところを説明していきます
このレッスンを見ると
皆様にも自分で瞑想の仕方がいろいろ発明できます
ポイントは実況中継すること
こういうことで実況します
こういうことでやりながら実況しますと
各自でいろんなことを考えることは自由でフリーでできます
まず この実況中継と集中力に慣れるためのレッスン1
今 私の前にものがあるんです
それで これはものを動かす瞑想と理解してください
私はこれを置いておいて
しっかりどのように置いたのかと覚えておくんです
この場合は 目で覚えておかなくちゃいけないんですね
目で覚えておいて 次に私は右利きです
ですから右手も覚え 置いておいて覚えておく
手を覚える場合は 目で覚えない
感覚で覚えるんです こういうふうに感覚で覚えるんです
前にあるもの 物体を目で覚えておく
目で覚えておくんです
なぜ目を使うのかというと
体に触れてないから このレッスンは
私はこれを取って右側に置いておく
右利きなので 左利きの方々は左に置いてください
それから手を元に戻す
それからもう一度それを取って運んで元に戻すという仕事をするんです
元に戻して 手も元に戻す
ここでポイントはいくつかあります
元に戻す を覚えておいてください
この元に戻すことは この記憶力の問題で
それからこの皆様に言葉で覚え教えられないことはいくつかの心の能力はあるんです
この間 説法でも言ったと思いますけど
この記憶力と 例えばお釈迦様がものすごい過去を思い出す能力を持っていたと
この過去の出来事を思い出すために
我々の心はインデックスを作るんですね
インデックスというのは日本語で言えば索引
索引です  索引を作るんですね
これはもうどんなものかと人わからないんです
ですから この索引を作ることを上手になってほしいんです
それは瞑想を進んだところで必要になるんです
時々自分の過去をちゃんと見られる方々も現れるんです
ヴィパッサナー瞑想でこの索引を作ることの達人なんですね
だからこの今 私は仮にペットボトルを使ったんだけど
これを見て ああ こんな感じにあるの？あるんだなと覚えておくんですね
言葉を使わないで そこで索引一つ作ったんです
そこで手を覚えて覚えてたんですね
そこでも感覚でああ こんな感覚と索引
頭の中で現れるんです
それを覚えておくんです
それで元に戻す 元に戻す場合は
買って使った インデックスを使用して元に戻すのです
その訓練でヴィパッサナー瞑想と同時に様々な能力
能力が開発していくんです
能力を開発するということは忘れてください
なぜならば欲が出てくるんだから
だから我々にはもういろいろな能力が隠れてあるんですよ
持っているもの 隠れているものは現れてきますから
心配しないで瞑想だけやってください
欲も出さないで ではレッスンに入ります
まずこの仕事は前半後半に分けます
前半後半に分けて前半をまず行います
前半行う場合は 前半というのはペットボトルを運ぶこと
それも小さなコマに切るんです
その仕事を 例えば手上げるだけの駒それ
それだけに来て完了した気分になるので
一仕事終わりましたと
小さなコマに切ってみると
皆様に一つの智慧が現れます
どんな仕事も我々は細かくやるんでしょうと
コマの一コマの仕事っていうのは笑うほど簡単なんです
これで笑うほど簡単なことをやって
なんで人生そんなに大変ですかというと
あれ妄想なんです 実際
妄想がなかったら誰だって笑っちゃしまうほどの簡単なことをやって生きているんです
これをわかった人には
人生は笑顔で満たしているのです
いつでも難しいことはすべて消えるんです
だからすごい得ですよ
それにはこのコマをコマにコマを切って仕事をするんだということは理解した方がよろしいのです
では 瞑想レッスン始まりましょう
で こまごまごとに私は余計なことも言いますから
皆さま方は余計なことをしないで実況中継だけでやってください
まず上げるというひとコマ
上げる 上げる 上げる 上げる
上げる 完了しましたね
次に伸ばすというひとコマ
伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす
伸ばす それで完了 それから下ろす
下ろす 下ろす 下ろす 下ろす
下ろす それから取る 取る
取る 取る 上げる 上げる
上げる 上げる 上げる 運ぶ
運ぶ 運ぶ 運ぶ 運ぶ 運ぶ
運ぶ 運ぶ 運ぶ 下ろす 下ろす
下ろす 下ろす 下ろす 下ろす
下ろす 下ろす 置く 置く
置く 置く 離す 離す 離す
離す 戻す 戻す 戻す 戻す
戻す 戻す 下ろす 下ろす
下ろす 下ろす 置く 置く
置く 置く それで手が元に元にあった通りに戻ったんですね
微妙にでもずれないようにしてほしいです
ずれたら別に罰があるわけではないのだから繰り返してください
前半終わりました 後半に行きます
上げる 上げる 上げる 上げる
伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす
伸ばす 取る 取る 取る 取る
上げる 上げる 上げる 上げる
運ぶ 運ぶ 運ぶ 運ぶ 運ぶ
運ぶ 下ろす 下ろす 下ろす
下ろす 下ろす 下ろす 下ろす
置く 置く 置く 置く 合わせる
合わせる 合わせる 離す
離す 離す 戻す 戻す 戻す
戻す 下ろす 下ろす 下ろす
下ろす 置く 置く 置く 置く
このペットボトルを元にあった通りに戻したんです
これがレッスン1 そこで皆様方の仕事はこの私が余計に言った言葉は忘れて
動詞だけで現在進行形で
実況中継するだけ 上げる
上げる 上げる 運ぶ 運ぶ
運ぶとかね だから あの言葉に困らなくていいんです
言葉に困ったら 自分の肉体が何をやっているのかとチェックしてください
肉体でやっていること
本当は肉体にできることは伸ばす縮むだけなんですね
でも相対的に体に相対的に上げる上げると言うんですね
で 体に相対的にこうやって前に曲がすか回すか動く
動くとなんとか適当な動詞でよろしいんですね
はい 体やってることだけ実況してください
現在進行形で これ一回うまくいかなかったら二回やってみる
三回もやってみる 難しいと感じたら感じても結構構いません
難しいと感じた方の心が頑張っているんですね
だから難しく感じたんです
別にどうしたことない
自分の仕事は頭いっぱい実況中継で保つこと
頭の中で瞬間も思考 雑念
妄想が返らないこと これを空性というんです
何も考えていない 考えていない状態
空性でやってみてください
こちら善悪はなし 正しい間違いということではなく
何もない無色透明の空性の精神でいられるようにと頑張ってください
これはこのレッスンの繰り返し
繰り返し 繰り返し 繰り返し
第1レッスンやってみてください
どんどん心が落ち着いてきます
どんどん上手になります
そこで何のことなく実況中継でできるようになります
そこで皆様方はレッスン2に進まなくちゃいけないんです
では レッスン1上手にできたところでレッスン2に行きます
レッスン2はもうちょっと難しくするんです
それにはこの裏があるんです
一つ繰り返しやると 脳の中であるループが出来上がっちゃうんですね
簡単にできるようにとループができちゃうと
ただオートメーションになっちゃって
オートでできるようになるんですね
そうすると脳が開発しないようになるんです
だから脳っていうのはもういかに怠けるのかと考えているんです
だから簡単にできるようになったら
難しいレッスンに行かなくちゃいけない
これは教育と同じことで
一つの勉強終わったらもうちょっと難しい勉強に挑戦しなくちゃいけないんですね
でないと脳は開発しないんです
はい レッスン2 レッスン2
ここで私にやってみせることはできませんので
説明だけします えっと
今度は 1個ではなくて
品物を5つ選ぶんです
一つ例を出しましょう
例えば 自分の部屋に本棚がありますね
本棚の本棚 一つの棚を見てください
見て この棚にある本5つぐらい
まあ片隅 右側でも左側でも
一箇所で本5つをちゃんと目で見て覚えておいてください
余計なことを言うならば
心で写真撮ってみてください
皆様 まあちょっともうまあふざけてね
携帯で写真撮ってもいいんだけど
瞑想には心で写真撮っておくんですね
はい それから上げる 上げる
上げる 上げる 伸ばす 伸ばす
伸ばす 撮る 撮る 撮る 撮る
運ぶ 運ぶ 運ぶ 運ぶ 置く
置く 置く 置く と実況中継して
本1冊をどこかに置いておく
どういう風に置いたってもいいんです
そちら決まりないんで
ただ置いておく それ終わった途端
まあ上げる 上げる 上げる
上げる 伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす
伸ばす 撮る 撮る 撮る 撮る
運ぶ 運ぶ 運ぶ 置く 置く
置く 置く と実況するんです
2冊目 初心者初めてやる方々はできるだけできることなら体を動かさないように
一箇所でいて手だけ動かしてやった方がやりやすいんです
上手になってくると 別なところに体を動かしておいても構いません
最初は体を動かさないで
手だけ動かして本を動かしておくんです
それで  3冊目も同じ実況中継で置いておく
4冊目も同じ実況中継で置いておく
5冊目も同じ実況中継で伸ばす
伸ばす伸ばす 取る取る取る
運ぶ運ぶ 置く置く置くと置いておく
それで前半が終わりました
後半始まります 元に戻すこと
これがちょっと難しい
インデックス機能 作為能力が今度必要になるんです
それで後半に入ります
伸ばす伸ばす伸ばす 取る取る取る取る
運ぶ運ぶ 運ぶ 運ぶ 置く置く置くと本を置いておくんです
その時 元にあった通りに置いておくんです
もしかすると 本の形やら本棚の形やら
隣の本のせいで元に戻せないかもしれませんだけど
後で直せますから その場合はそういう問題なかったら
全部硬い本ばっかしの本棚だったら
隣の問題は出てこない
それで 2番目の本 また伸ばす伸ばす
取る取る取る 運ぶ運ぶ
置く置く置く  3番目も 3番目と言わない
取る取る取る 運ぶ運ぶ運ぶ
置く置く置く また伸ばす伸ばす伸ばす
取る 運ぶ 置く それで 5冊目までゆっくりと元に戻しちゃうんです
5冊目終わったら 本棚が元通りになってほしいんです
ちょっとも間違いなく
そこは修行のポイントなんです
元通りになること それは記憶力だけではなくて
精神的に落ち着くためにも
いわゆる集中力 そういういくつかの能力をこれで開発してもらいます
だから ものすごい真剣にこれ行ってみてください
最初は難しいんですよ
難しくてもやってみて
うまくいかなかったらもう一回繰り返してやって
もう一回繰り返してやる
だいたい時間的にも5分ぐらい
7分ぐらいだと思いますけど
一回終わるまではね そういう程度でやってみてください
このレッスンの繰り返し
繰り返し 繰り返しやってみてください
それで 5つは6に7冊に8 10冊には伸ばして伸ばさないでください
あ できちゃった では10冊にするとは
それは欲張りなんですね
それぐらいは能力は脳にないんです
ですから この脳にも負担にならないように気をつけてほしいんですから
あの数字は 5 なんですね
5つですね  5つにして
繰り返し繰り返しやってください
これはサンプルで言ったことなんですね
あるいは自分 のテーブルの上で品物を 5個ダラダラと置いておいて
整理整頓しないでダラダラと置いておいて
それを運んで床に降りて
また運んでテーブルの上に元の通りに置いておく
あの整理整頓しないしちゃうと
あの怠けるんです 脳が
だから品物を 5個トントントントンと置いておく
置いてから覚えていくんです
そこでインデクシングするんです
インデクシングは心が勝手にやるんだから
皆様にはそれにアクセスできませんよ
ですから それから運んで元に戻す
テーブルの上にできるんです
あるいはもう クローゼットの服をね
ハンガーのまんまで 5着を運ぶこともできるし
何でもできますよ もう何か品物一つ選んで運んで元に戻す
運んで元に戻すっていう訓練をやってみてください
はい それではちゃめちゃ実況中継しないと修行にはなりません
はい それでレッスンツー終わります
はい 次 あの レッスンツーのもう一つ
この付属実践紹介します
これは集中力があまりない
イライラする性格がある方々に集中力がないと落ち着いてないとね
いわゆる落ち着きの力があまりない方々にすごく必要なことだと思います
これはティッシュを折ることなんです
で 実況中継でティッシュ 1枚を取る
取って実況中継でゆっくりとできるだけゆっくり実況しながら上げる上げる上げる
何でしたっけね 言葉は出てこないんだけど
上げる上げる 曲げる 曲げるとかね
置く 置く 合わせる 合わせるとか合わせると言って
ぴったし 2つに折るんです 2
つに折って 手でも撫でるとかね
手でもうプレスするとかね
英語の単語だったら言いますけどね
プレッシングプレッシングといって
プレスしてぴったし2枚に折る
ティッシュを選んだのは
あの折り紙を選べないでください
折り紙は簡単に折れます
ティッシュはいい加減な品物なんです
私のわがままを聞いてくれないんです
ですから ちょっと難しいんです
綺麗に 2つに折れる場合も
折れない場合もあります
それも理解してほしいんです
何でも私のせいじゃないとね
何でも自分希望通りにいかないっていうこともあります
それで 2つに折ったら
もう一度 上げる上げる上げる
曲げる 曲げる 曲げる 曲げる
置く 置く 置く 合わせる
合わせる 合わせる 押す
押す 押す 押す 押す 押す
押す 押すと 4つに折ってみるんです
そこでポイントはぴったし綺麗にパーフェクトに 4つに折ることなんです
4つに折ることができたならば
8つに折ってみるんです
そこで楽しくやってください
2つに折れたことはよかった
よくできたというふうな感じで
ちょっと気持ちよくなってみてください
よかったよかったと言わないでください
ただ 言葉ないこと 気持ちで気持ちよくなってみてください
それで 4つに折ることができたら
もうこれできれいに 4つに折れましたと
いい作品できましたっていう気分に言葉を使わす
その気持ちになってください
よくできたっていう あの微妙な喜びも感じてください
それでずっと実況中継するんです
何も考えないで  4つに折れたらもう 8つに折ることになりますけどね
まあ 8つにはそんなに美しくは折れないと思います
それでもやってみてください
そうすると どんな結果になったのかとわかりますね
それ終わったらティッシュを捨ててください
それで結構集中力が生まれるとは思います
それはレッスンツーの付属的なレッスンですね
はい そこでレッスンスリー説明します
レッスンツーできた方々にとっては
ものすごくできるようになったら
もうちょっと難しくしないと
脳開発はできなくなります
そこでレッスン３になるんです
レッスン３の場合は 難しくするよりは
いろいろ智慧の世界を広げてみることになるんですね
で これにあの タイトルは作りにくいんだけど
迷子になったものは元に戻すという風に言ってもいいんだけど
もうちょっと面白くやります
まずサンプル説明したらわかりやすい
修行者がリビングに行ってみたら
リビングに掃除機があるんですね
リビングに掃除機があるとは
掃除機がリビングにあってはならないんです
掃除機には置く場所があるんですね
そこで あるストーリーを作るんです
このストーリーが大事なんです
ストーリーだから嘘ですよ
でも これはとても大事なんです
こう思うんです 掃除機様が迷子になっている
なんで掃除機様にしたんですかね
自分のエゴをちょっと控えてほしいんです
俺様は消してほしいんです
その代わりに掃除機様が迷子になっている
そこで自分が掃除機様を実況中継で
掃除機様のお城にとても丁寧に戻ってあげてください
では やり方 実況中継 伸ばす
伸ばす 伸ばす 取る 取る
取る 上げる 上げる 上げる
運ぶ 運ぶといってもよろしいし
左足 右足 左足 右足 左足
右足といってもいいし
それからまあまあ各自の各皆様の家にドアあるかわかりませんだけど
もうそのまま置くこともできるし
ドアを開けておく場合もあるし
ドアを押して開ける場合もあるし
引いて開ける場合もあるし
それなりに押すか引くか何とか言って
それも実況する 押すドアだったら押す押す押すと
引くものだったら引く引く引くと
それから置く 置く 置く
置くと 掃除機様という気持ちで丁寧に美しく置いておいてください
置いておいて 離す 離す
離す ドアだったら押す
押す 押す で 終わり これはレッスン３なんですね
そこで今サンプルで説明しました
皆様には家の中であらゆる迷子になっている様たちが見つかるんです
ご自分のテーブルの上見たら
鉛筆様が迷子になっている
ボールペン様が迷子になっている
クリップでもクリップ様が迷子になっている
消しゴム様が迷子になっている
その時 何々様が迷子になっているという気持ちで
運ぶ 運ぶ 運ぶ 入れる 入れると
そのその品物が住んでいる場所に戻してあげてください
キッチンに行ったら お皿様やら包丁様やらね
なんていったっけ まな
様やらいろんな様たちが迷子になっているんです
それは実況中継で元に戻すんです
ものすごく気持ちよくなるはずなんです
すごくなんか人生が明るくなってくるんです
そこで玄関に靴様が迷子になっているわ
いろんなもの 服が迷子になっているわ
例えば使った服 洗濯機に回さなくちゃいけない
そのまま放り投げるでしょうに
それで迷子になっていますね
それもそれなりに洗濯する
バケツ バケツあったならば
そちらに丁寧に迷子になっているんですということで
実況中継で上げる 入れる
上げる 入れる 上げる 入れると
で 一つにまとめておく
そういうことで 玄関始めて
家の片っ端から隅から隅までいろんな品物たちが迷子になっているのは見える
雑誌様が開けたまんまで迷子になっているわ
新聞様が広げたまんまで迷子になっているわ
それは実況中継で畳んで
その雑誌新聞様が住むところに戻ってあげてください
実況中継で それで人生いかに楽しいかと皆様経験するんです
何もしなくても喜びが出てくるはずなんです
その喜びという機能が必要なんです
それは七覚支に入っているもので
解脱に達する人は常に喜びを感じる性格にならなくちゃいけないんですね
だから この悪のない純然たる善の喜びを感じる方法なんです
純粋な善の喜び ただ掃除機をかけるで喜びを感じる
玄関の靴を揃ってあげて喜びを感じる
よくできたという感じの喜びを感じる
そうすると脳がこのすごいネガティブ思考を止めて止めて
脳がすごくリラックスして喜びを感じると
脳みそもじりじりと成長するんです
仏教の瞑想は脳みその開発ではないんだから
心の開発ですからね ついでに脳という道具も一応サビがなくなっちゃって
脂が入っちゃって 栄養が入って結構成長するんです
心の開発するんです 心は死後でも持っていけますけど
脳みそは持って行けませんので
それはただの道具なんです
はい これはレッスン３なんですね
そこであらゆる迷子になっているものを見つけてやってみてください
会社に行ったら 会社の自分の机の上でも迷子になっているものが見つかるわ
他のところでも迷子になっているものは見つかるわ
会社でお茶を飲んだり
お湯出たり場所があるんですね
そちらに行ったら 他の人々は勝手にカップを取ったり
お茶入れて飲んで そのまま放り投げて出て行ったりする場合ありますね
それでもこの人はだらしない
誰がこれカップこっちに置いたのかと思っちゃうと
俗世間の悪世界なんです
それは何のことなく 誰がお茶を飲んでもいいんだけど
カップはそのまま洗ってもないで
あったならば あ カップ様が汚れて迷子になっていると言って
自分が思って取る取る取る
洗う洗う洗う 拭くは拭きます
拭きます 拭きます 置きます
置きます 置いてください
すごく楽しみが生まれてくるんです
そこで人に指を指す性格がなくなるんです
あの人のせい あの人のせい
なんで人はこんなにだらしないのか
例えば家庭の奥様だったら
玄関靴はハチャメチャですから
ものすごく怒るんですね
なんだこれ 何回言ったらわかるんですかと
じゃあ家族のみんな 家族がいてもいなくても怒るんです
それで家の仕事っていうのはすごくストレスかかる仕事になるんです
だから 靴をハチャメチャにしたのは誰でもいいんだから
靴様が迷子になっている
自分が丁寧に元に戻ってあげる
それだけ それですごく素晴らしく
性格の良い人間になると思います
はい これでレッスン３は終わります
はい ではレッスン４に入ります
で どんどん我々はヴィパッサナーと智慧の生きることは何ぞやと
そういう方に瞑想を進んで持っていきます
で 生きるということはどうったことはないんでしょう
動いているだけなんですね
いろんなことをして動いている
で 犬猫であろうが 動物であろうか
人間であろうか もう動くは動く
それだけで生きることはね
ご飯食べることも動くことで
料理作ることは動くことで体を動かしている
体を動かしているんです
その中でそんなに深い得体知れない
知り得ない 神しか知らない真理が隠れているわけじゃないんです
それで我々は悩んだり困ったり
失敗したりするのは動きの世界なんですね
はい そこでレッスン４は
我々毎日やりたいかやりたくないで関係なく避けられない仕事があるんですね
避けたらちょっと困ったことになる
特にこのマンネリで行うこととかね
結構あるんですね やめてもいいんだけど
やめたらちょっとまずいんですね
例えば服を洗うことをね
服を洗わなかったからって人は死ぬわけじゃないんだけどね
でも全然洗わないで置いておいちゃうとちょっとまずい
で 朝起きたら布団を片付ける
布団片付けないでそのままもう 1ヶ月間もそのまま放っておいたからといって
まあまあダニとか何とか出てくるかもしれませんだけど
別にどうったことはないんですね
時々我々は嫌がって まあ後でやりますっていうことは後回しにするんですね
で 歯を磨くこととかね
やらなかったからといって死ぬわけじゃないんだけど
マンネリで必ずやらなくちゃいけない
はい そこで嫌で嫌でやっている場合も
面倒くさいなとかね 歯を磨くのかいとかね
子供みたいな 大人も言わないんだけど
子供と同じ 歯を磨かなくちゃいけない
うるさいな これはとか思ったりするんですよ
それでちょっと心にダメージが入るんです
怒りが入るんです 怠けが成長するんです
例えば 朝起きて座布団
まあ今は面倒くさい うるさいんだから
もう早くご飯食べて出かけると
そのまま置いておいてね
もう帰ってからやりますと
そこで怠けが入っているんですね
嫌な気持ちが入っているんですよ
それから後で思い出しちゃうと
ああ嫌だなという気持ちも出てくるんです
だからわざわざ我々はそのウイルスを作って自分の心を感染させるんですね
そこで瞑想を持ってくるんですね
例えば歯を磨くことで
歯を磨く場合は 実況中継で体が手がやっている動作だけ
体がやっている動作だけ実況中継してください
例えば歯磨く歯磨きを取る場合は
伸ばす 伸ばす 取る 取る
これから歯磨きを取りますと言っちゃうと
なんか法則的な実況中継になるんです
そうではなくて 伸ばす
伸ばす 取る 取る それから歯ブラシあるでしょ
伸ばす 伸ばす 取る 当てる
絞る 伸ばす 伸ばす 置く
それから当てる 引き押す
引き押す 引き押す 引き押す
引き押す 上下だったらもう上げる
下げる 上げる 下げる そういう風に実況中継するんです
で 体がやっていること
だから前のレッスンやってない人にとっては
これは相当難しいんです
嫌になってくるんです
レッスンちゃんと合格した人にとっては
これで結構難しいレッスンでよかったねと気持ちいいんだよということになるんです
それで歯も綺麗に磨き磨けるし
気分もいいし 朝目覚めた途端
それで 実況中継で布団を畳んでちゃんと運ぶ
置く その場合も元に戻すという気持ちで丁寧にぴったし置くと
もう気分爽快なんですよ
そんなほんのわずかな時間でできる
ご飯食べたらもうもう今忙しい後で
朝ご飯の皿もあのあれ
洗い置き場にあるし 昼ご飯のものもあって
晩ご飯のものもあって
じゃあ明日休みだから明日全部まとめて洗うぞと思うと
一日一日中気持ち悪いでしょうに
台所に行くたびに気持ち悪いでしょうに
自分の怠けがね 後回しにする悪い性格という細菌が自分を崩壊して破壊していくんですよ
だからそれやめましょうよと
瞑想しましょうと 朝ご飯食べて終わったら
もうこれはもうやらなくていい仕事なんですけど
やらなかったら死ぬわけじゃないんだけど
ちゃんと取ったものを全部綺麗に洗って拭いて
実況中継で取る 洗う 拭く
引く 置くとかね 体でやっていることだけ実況してください
コーヒーカップを取るではなくて
伸ばす 取る 水の場合はジャグ伸ばす
あ 何とか手でね 回す回すとかね
それから置く それだけ
名詞使わないで普段より早くできます
仕事は それから仕事終わったら何か気分爽快
そういうふうに皿洗うことやら洗濯することやら
家の掃除とかね 掃除しますよ
それから掃除機を取る
上げる 運ぶ 置く それからコードだったら
まあ今ほとんどコードないもの使ってますけどね
コードだったら引くとか引く
押すや差すとかね スイッチの場合でもスイッチを押しますではなくて押す
それから引き押す 引き押す
引き押す 引き押す で テーブルがあったらこれは置く
テーブルを上げる 運ぶ
置く また掃除機を取る
押す 引き押す 引き押す
引き押す この頭いっぱい実況するんです
それで早くも掃除機が出る
掃除は終わるし 盲点はないし
盲点というんですかね
忘れたところもない ないし
あ ここもやらなくちゃ
ここもやらなくちゃ なんとなく興味が出てくるんです
で 時間も早いし 仕事も完璧に出来上がっちゃうし
結果として気分爽快です
目の前で結果が出るんです
この瞑想で このセクションで
このレッスンで で すごい気持ちよくなって
このレッスン この今フォーですからね
レッスン4 4番目になってくると
ものすごく集中力あるはずなんです
すごくなんか人生が楽しく感じられるはずなんです
なんか日常生活では難しいことっていうのは何もないでしょうと
困ることは何もないでしょうとわかってきますよ
実は日常生活の中で困ることは何もないんです
今 コロナウイルスが流行する時代
時期でね コロナウイルスの問題があって困ると
困らなくてもいいんです
別に 何も我々にとっては
ウイルスに感染しないためにやらなくちゃいけないけど
大変なことあるわけじゃないんです
ごく普通の生き方でそれを管理できるんです
だから たとえそういうふうに世界的な伝染病が広がったからといって
ヴィパッサナー瞑想の人にはいつでも穏やかに笑顔でいられますよ
それプラスアルファで
プラスアルファでもないんだけど
それに対応することもできる
例えば手がすごい感染する手段だからね
手は汚れて手に汚れがあるかもと実況中継でわかる人がちゃんと手を綺麗にして
で 体に感染しないようにすると
だから気づきがサティが実況中継で生きてみれば
もう問題ないんですよ
人間のはもう悩み苦しみというのは
あのね 妄想の問題なんです
でなきゃ自然はそのままで何のこともないんです
はい 余計な話で時間なくなりましたので
そうやって実況中継で日常生活で避けて通らないもの
真なりでやらなくちゃいけないこと
雑巾かけることは 掃除機をかけることやら
皿洗いことやら 洗濯することや
洗濯の干すこと 干したそれから元に戻すこと
アイロンかけること ああいうものは実況中継でやるんです
アイロンかけるときで実況中継してみて下さい
すごく楽しくなってくるし
すごい上手になってくるんです
たとえ下手な人でも 実況中継でやっちゃうと
ものの見事にうまく出来上がっちゃうんです
アイロンかける時でも
例えばもうシャツのアイロンがかけられません
私には と悩んでいる人は妄想ばっかりで
実況中継でシャツを見たらシャツの形見えるし
シャツ様だから シャツ様はここをこうやるべき
ここはこうやるべき それからこうやって畳むべきと見えてくるんです
それでプロと同じくシャツのアイロンかけて畳んで立派な出来になるんですよ
ただ実況中継でやってください
レッスン順番でやってください
レッスン順番でやったら
そこをそういう風にやることは何でもプロらしくできるようになりますね
はい それがレッスンフォーで
日々避けられないことにヴィパッサナー瞑想を入れてみるという訓練でございます
ありがとうございます
はい 次 レッスンファイブ
五に行きます これからもうブッダの世界
智慧の世界 ヴィパッサナー瞑想のこの解脱を目指す瞑想の道に入ります
そのための下準備ですね
やったのは 集中力がある
喜びを感じられる 悩み苦しみもない
明るい 超越したものに挑戦できる人間
精神の体ができてから次に行くんです
レッスンファイブに行くんです
レッスンファイブは やらなかったら死ぬことに瞑想するんです
いくらなんでもこれやらなかったら死にます
そこでこのやらなかったら死ぬこと
まずリスト作ってみましょう
それで智慧が現れます
一 一は呼吸なんです 呼吸しなかったら死ぬんです
それで考えてください
ただ 空気が入ったり出たり
入ったり出たり これで命なんです
なんでつまらないんですかね
何も尊くでも何でもないんです
ただの自然の流れなんです
空気が入ったり出たり
入ったり出たりするだけ
これ止めたら人は死ぬんです
地球上の生命は誰だって死ぬんです
だから神様のおかげではなくて
空気のおかげ様でしょうに
だから一 呼吸 それを見ると
呼吸って大胆なことじゃない
あの中国文化でインド文化で教えている
あの宗教っぽい迷信っぽい物語を捨ててください
呼吸にあって 気が動いてあって
すごい宇宙のエネルギーが体に入るとか
あんなのもう非科学的な迷信の物語捨てて
目の前で空気が入ったり出たりするだけなんです
我々 宇宙空間の空気吸ってるわけじゃないんです
目の鼻の先にある空気を吸っているんです
だから見たら この空気
こちらにある空気が鼻から中に入って出ていく
それだけ それで命なんです
空気 それからやらなかったら死ぬこと
またありますよ 食べること
食べなかったら死にます
肉体の中でたくさんの栄養を保管していますからね
朝ご飯食べなかったら死ぬわけじゃないんです
昼ご飯食べれなかったら死ぬわけじゃないんです
大体 7 日間ぐらい  1週間ぐらい食べなくたっても人は死にませんよ
その間で体に保管している栄養は使いますけど
その分体がすごく痩せますね
で それから死にますよ
もう だから 知識的に言えば
脳みそに あの 何て言いますか
砂糖ですけど グルコースですけどね
なくなったら 1 分ももたないんです
だから本当は我々はもう 24時間栄養を取っているんです
細胞ははじけちゃうんです
あの糖尿病で薬ちょっと飲んだら
時々ガクンと血液 血糖が下がっちゃうと倒れるでしょ
コマになっちゃうでしょ
コマになっちゃうと もう復活もできないんです
壊れたところはもう壊れたままで
脳の脳細胞がいかに危険かと
だから呼吸と空気と同じ
もう 24時間 毎秒毎秒ずっと細胞に栄養が入らなくちゃいけない
我々は物質取り入れは 1 日 3回か4回か 20
回もある人いるかもしれませんだけどね
で まあそれはやりすぎで
まあそれはね 大体まあ 1 日 1回だけでも物質を取り入れなくちゃいけないんですね
次のもの 排泄 死にはやらなかったら死にます
例えば尿でも小尿でも出さないで我慢したら
ものの見事にその人は死ぬんです
だから命の価値って何ですかね
便所に行かなかったら死に
死んでしまうぐらいの命でしょ
で 食べなかったら死んでしまう命でしょ
呼吸止まったら死んでしまう命でしょ
だから心臓が止まったら人が死ぬっていうことは
心臓が止まったからって人は死にません
心臓が止まったら物質
心臓はあれでしょ 宅急便だからね
宅急便の本社だからね
酸素と栄養が運べなくなっちゃうんです
各細胞に それで細胞たちが死ぬんです
心臓が止まったからって大したことない
手術とか 医者も心臓を止め止めさせるでしょうに
無理やり それで死にません
死ぬのはもう栄養がなくなったら 1 分終わり
さようなら 酸素がなくなったら 2 分
さようなら はい そこをそのリストなんですね
っていれば 大したリストじゃないね
呼吸と食べるものと排泄ですね
これが命の 3 原則です
恥ずかしいでしょうね
すごい神様の贈り物だと思っていたんだけどね
だから この命に対する執着を一応控えましょう
こんなくだらんもんなんです
生きるっていうことは
では それを瞑想に使いましょう
で 今度 ヴィパッサナー瞑想の場合は
私は個人的にあえてこの呼吸の瞑想っていうのはちょっと置いておくんです
置いておくのはやってはいけないことではなくて
ちょっとやり方が少々変わったりして
それだけで完全フルバージョンの瞑想になっちゃうんですね
だから他の他のことは入れられなくなっちゃうんです
お釈迦様がこの呼吸瞑想が完全フルバージョンで解脱に達するまで別に教えてあるんですね
だから我々は四念処経の元を参考に
それを元にしてヴィパッサナー瞑想を教えているんだから
あの軽く教えられますけど
それ以上は説明しないことにはするんですね
だから私は自分の自己判断で
あの このリストの中で残り実況してくださいと言うんです
食べる瞑想と排泄の時の瞑想
で 排泄時の瞑想っていうのは
まあちょっとあまりそれで悟るというケースは記録されてないんだけど
やっぱりその時でも体やってることは伸ばすとる引くとかね
で 実況してみてください
それから 排泄する前の感覚
すごい嫌な感覚 それからどんどんその嫌な感覚がなくなって
普通の感覚に戻るという
この感覚変換もチェックして
あ 気持ち悪いか 今気持ち悪い感覚です
どんどん減っていく その気持ち悪い感覚が減っていく
それで落ち着き 普通の感覚に戻りました
そこらもちょっと実況つけて
そこのトイレの他のこともね
綺麗にすることやらね
まあトイレの修行 結構出家にありますよ
それは最近ではあまり関係ないか
言わないかどうか分からんだけどね
トイレは入ったら出る前
出る前に元通りにしなくちゃいけないんです
何一つ物を動かしてはいけないんです
ものは何を使ってもいいんです
使ったものを全て元に戻すんです
水一滴でも落ちたら それは拭いておかなくちゃいけないんです
次の人 入る人にとっては
もう誰も入ってない通りやっていう気持ちになるようにしなくちゃいけないという決まりがあるんです
仏教では で そこを考えていけば瞑想になるんです
で 元に戻しますとかね
そこで瞑想でしょ で 手順を取ったり
だからトイレットペーパーとかね
だからもう取ったままでダラーンと落ちても
そのまま出て行く場合は気持ち悪いんで
やっぱり元にどうあったのかといって
そこは元にちゃんと戻して
そういう風に実況中継しながらトイレの用事を済む
それでも心の安らぎ 落ち着きが生まれてくる
そこで瞑想を通してやるのは食べる瞑想なんです
食べる瞑想はもういきなり解脱を目指してやっていることだから
これからちょっと厳しくはなります
時間的に四十五分五分ぐらい用意してください
それから 食べる間では誰とも喋れない
コミュニケーション完全にカットする
いわゆるこの出家状態を作る
俗世間からきれいに切り離した
離した状態を作らなくちゃいけない
だから首を振ってでも人とコミュニケーションはしない
ちょっと厳しいんです
時間が四十五分程度 それから一旦仕事を
どんな仕事でも始めたら
その仕事を終わるまでやりなさいという仏教の道徳があるんです
一つの仕事を途中でやめて
もう一つの仕事を始めて
それを途中でやめて もう一つの仕事を辞めて
それを途中でやめてとか
そういう性格は悟りを目指す人には良くないんです
例えばボールペンで何か書いて
そのまま置いておいて
なことを始める あとでボールペン片付きますと
それはダメなんです そういうことで
全てこの食べる瞑想で揃ってもらいます
その道徳を食べ始めたら立ってはいけない
何か物を取ってはいけない
食べ始めたら 食べることを完了して終わらなくちゃいけない
それでやり方なんですけど
人と喋ってはいけないんだから
奥様方には簡単ですね
家の人々は出て行っちゃったら
自分一人だけだから瞑想はできます
そうでない場合は まあ自分の部屋でドア閉めて瞑想すればいいのです
それでも誰かがドアに叩く恐れがあるならば
ちょっとあれ書いといてください
メモを この時間からこの時間まで
なんとか何とかね 入るなよと
ドアを叩くなよと いうふうな看板でも書いて
みんな追い出した方がいいんです
それで出家環境を作らなくちゃいかんです
出家っていうのは 頭剃って心も切ることじゃないんです
俗世間から離れることなんです
純粋に裸の命になることなんです
ただ生き物になることなんです
それで 自分の部屋で食べるものを全部運んでください
あ もう一つ忘れちゃった
普段食べる食事一つ選んでください
3食食べる人は 朝ご飯
昼ご飯 晩ご飯の一つを選ぶ
2食の場合は一つ選ぶとか
4食5食の人は置いておきましょう
で それで朝ご飯でも昼ご飯でも晩ご飯でもいいんだけど
その時食べるものは全部テーブルに用意しておく
水を飲むならば水も用意しておく
途中でお醤油かける計画だったらお醤油も入れておく
コショウもかける計画だったらコショウも入れておく
お茶も飲む計画だったらお茶も置いておく
要するに全てまず揃ってもらう
揃ってもらったら それから瞑想始まります
おすおすとか何とか言ってドアを閉じて
それから座りますね  しゃがむ
しゃがむ しゃがむ 座ります
座りますと座ってください
それから両手を膝の上に置きます
それは実況中継 置きます
置きます 置きます と 名詞使わない
そこでもう食卓の前で全部綺麗に並んで
自分の好きなように並んで整理してありますね
当然一番前にあるのはお箸ですね
じゃあ 1個だけ説明します
あの箸を取る仕事 だから細か動きでやるんです
箸を取る仕事 それで手上げる
上げる上げる 伸ばす 伸ばす
伸ばす 取る 取る 取る その仕事を完了
それから箸を挟まないと何も取れませんね
手で取ってから挟むんだからね
それから挟む仕事 挟む
挟む 挟む それでその仕事は完了
それから何か食べるものを取るんですね
その場合は伸ばす 伸ばす
伸ばす 伸ばす 取る 取る
取る その仕事終わった
それから運ぶんです 運ぶ
運ぶ 運ぶ 運ぶ 運ぶ 口元まで運ぶんです
その仕事 運ぶ仕事終わりました
それから開ける 入れる
閉じる 口に食事 食べるものを入れました
閉じたら閉じた その仕事を一旦ストップするんです
ストップして手がこちらにあるんだから
下ろす 下ろす 下ろす 下ろす
下ろす 下ろす 置く 置く
置くと 箸を元に置いてください
元通りに この瞑想 厳しいんです
置く 置く 置く それから手戻す
戻す 戻す 置く 置く 置く
置く 置く 手は元に戻すんです
それから停止させた口の中の仕事
順番です 口の中で噛む
噛む 噛む 味わう 噛む 噛む
噛む 味わう 噛む 噛む 味わう
飲み込む 言葉はどんな通りでもいいんですね
噛む 味わう 味わう 噛む
噛む 噛む 味わうとかね
できるだけ全部噛んでください
知らんうちに飲み込む場合は
これやめてください ちゃんと飲み込むと実況中継でやるんです
修行だからね 文句言わないでください
食べるとか なんとなく口にお腹に入りますよと
これはダメです 気づきがあって入れるんです
飲み込む で 噛む場合も丁寧に感じながら
味わいながら 噛む 噛む
味わう 噛む 噛む 味わう
で 飲み込む ある人が質問したんです
なんか美味しく感じますよと
美味しいと言ったら何が悪いんですかと
悪いんです 美味しいっていうのは妄想の働きなんです
食べ物の美味しいまずいっていうことはないんです
各人の主観妄想なんです
私が美味しいという食べるものには
他の人は美味しいとは言わないんです
だからあくまでも妄想の結果なんです
科学じゃないんです だから美味しいという漢字は使いません
もし美味しいと感じてしまったならば
美味しく感じていると言ってください
そこでみんな失敗しているのは
美味しいではなくて それは別な法則なんです
人間には草を食べられないんですね
笹の葉っぱも食べられませんね
ゆかりの葉っぱも食べられませんね
それ食べてみると不味いんです
いわゆる自然法則が 遺伝子がこれ食うなよと
私には分解できませんと言っているだけなんです
それで焼き芋を取って食っちゃうと
おお 結構美味しいね これはと
それは美味しいではなくて
細胞たちがこれなら分解できますよと言っているだけなんです
ですから 鳥たちには昆虫が美味しいんです
昆虫 皆様食べてみてください
何の味もないんです と言ったって私は食べたことはないんです
何の味もないことだけは知ってます
で 虫食べる鳥たちもいるでしょ
虫も味がないんでしょうね
例えばミミズを取って食べたりすると
ミミズにはどんな味でしょうかね
でもその生命体にそれは美味しいんです
で 藁食べるでしょ？牛は
人間から見れば藁って食べられないで美味しくないでしょうにと
不味いでしょ でも牛さんがよだれ垂らしながら食べているんです
だから動物より成長しましょうよ
人間という種に チキンやら豚やらね
牛肉やらご飯やらジャガイモやらサツマイモやらね
キャベツ レタスとかね
いくつかの食べ物は食べられますよ
そんなに幅広くはないんです
人間食べるものはすごく狭い範囲なんです
で 中国人が反対するかもしれませんだけど
で 狭い範囲のものなんですよ
だからそれは美味しいと感じるのは
美味しいではなく 体に合う
それだけなんです だから
例えば 焼き魚が好きな人を見て嫌いやー！という人もいますよ
なんで？その人の体に合わないんです
それだけ だからこの美味しいと言わないでください
ちょっと雑談になりましたけどね
噛む 噛む 味わう 噛む 噛む
味わう 味を感じる そこまでは 100%の正しい客観的な事実なんです
すべての生命に共通する事実なんです
味を感じる その味が体に合うならば
肉体に合うならば その人は馬鹿だったら美味しいと言う
それだけ で だから味わう
飲み込む それでワンセクション終わったでしょ
相当仕事量なんです 実況中継でやると
それ終わったらもう一度手上げる
上げる上げる 伸ばす伸ばす
取る取る取る 挟む挟む挟む
それから伸ばす 伸ばす伸ばす
取る取る取る 運ぶ運ぶ運ぶ
開ける 入れる 閉じる 戻す戻す
戻す 戻す 置く 置く 置く
戻す戻す 戻す 戻す 置く
置く 置く それから噛む
噛む 噛む 味わう 噛む 噛む
味わう 噛む 噛む 味わう
飲み込む で 次のものを食べるんです
ここで注意点は 魚を取ると名詞使いません
ご飯を取ると名詞使いません
目にあるのはホモ・サピエンスサピエンスたちに食べられるものです
だからただの食べるものです
そこでラベル貼っちゃうと妄想の世界
焼き魚が体に 白身白身魚というんですか？白身魚がすごいコレステロールにいい
いいかどうかよくわかりません
私はいい加減で喋ってますけどね
白身魚の方がコレステロールが少なくて健康にいいとかね
牛肉食べるならば和牛の方が一番最高やとかね
これって全て頭イカれてる病気な人々
妄想の世界 幻想の世界なんです
ただの食べるものなんですね
動物の言葉で言えばただの餌です
キャベツであろうとも
ジャガイモであろうと
だからそれ言わない 取る
運ぶという感じでやってください
途中でお茶飲む時でも
水飲む時でも同じく伸ばす
伸ばす 取る 取る 運ぶ 運ぶ
入れる 飲み込む 入れる
口の中に入れる 飲み込む
で 運ぶ 運ぶ 置く 置く 置く
そういう感じで食事をしてみてください
45分かかるということも意味わかると思います
45分はかかる でもこれは純粋な悟りに達する瞑想なんです
修行者は誰でもやるんです
ブッダの時代から だから偉大なる聖なる阿羅漢たちも実践した瞑想
そのままなんです だから
すごい尊い気持ちでやってみてください
そこで智慧が現れてくるんです
今までいかに苦しんで食べたのかと
いかに欲で傲慢で見栄で食っていたのかと
体に合うか合わないか関係なく
見栄で食べている アメリカ大統領もこれ食べてるんだから私も食べましょうとかね
そういう人間なんですよ
もうあまりにも無知なんですね
誰か何だらかんだら 丸々の有名人がよくこれこのラーメン食べて
このお店でラーメン食べたことテレビで見たんだから
じゃあ行きましょうって言って
1名と1キロぐらい並んで
ただのラーメン食うために並んでるんですね
だから恥ずかしく感じないんですかね
どこでもラーメンラーメンだからね
そんなラーメンにはもう天国から味を持ってきて味付けしているわけないでしょうに
それだったら人間に食べられないでしょうに
どこ行ったの？とんこつラーメンとか塩みそラーメンとか
だからいかに自分がもうもう脳みそが抜かれたアホみたく生きてきたのかということ見えてくるんです
それ知恵なんです 食べるものに対しても
これから余計な悩み 苦しみ
探し求めることはしない人間に自動的になるんです
口に入るもので十分やということになるんです
それで健康のためにあれこれと選ばなくてもいいんです
今 宇宙法則で食べてるんだから
食べたものから体がすべて必要なものを取るんです
問題はないんです 例えばある修行者に 3日続けて白いご飯しかなかったと
全然病気にならない 瞑想で食べたならば
でも瞑想じゃなくて妄想するでしょ？ああ
まあしょうがない まあ修行中で白い白いご飯しかない
修行終わった途端 まあもう焼き肉とご飯食べますよ
あれは病気ですよ もう体が壊れますよ
病気になります 肉体の
だって体に言ってるんだから
この心が食べるものを処理するでしょ
心に言って これはろくなものじゃないよと
だから心もろくなものだ
もうゴミ処分するような感じで処分するんだから
体にゴミが入っちゃったようなになる
それ何のこともなく 善悪を捨てて
美味しい不味い捨てて運ぶ取る入れる
かむかむ味わうでやったら全然問題は起きません
これは神秘でも迷信でもなく
ヴィパッサナー瞑想っていうのは副作用0の唯一なものなんです
世の中にある 全てに副作用があるんです
ヴィパッサナー瞑想ではないんです
だから瞑想で食べてみてください
ものの見事に健康になるんです
それ言っちゃうと健康になる
じゃあ私もやると そしたらアウト
欲はダメなんです 解脱に達するために瞑想してください
はい そういうことで 食べる場合はね
その瞑想をやっていると
それで見えてくるんですね
いかに欲で食べたのかと
焦って食べていたのかと
体に負担になるように食べていたのかと
わがままで食べていたのかと
あるいはもったいない
もったいないと食ってしまったのではないかどうか
いろんなことを見えてくるんです
あ これは高価なもの これは高級レストランのシェフが作ったカレーですとかあるんで
なんかどこかのホテルのシェフが作ったカレーという最近見たんだけどね
ただ食べてみたら ただの日本のカレーなんですけどね
看板で食べている 看板食っちゃえばいいでしょうに
だから我々はいかに煩悩によって操られているんですね
妄想に操られているんです
幻覚に操られているんです
それがなくなります それで食べるものってそんなに執着する必要する必要ないんだと
しかし 食べることって結構苦しいことやと
面倒くさいんだと なのにそれやらなかったら命は成り立たないんだと
だから それでも苦労して苦労して
なんで食っているのかと
なんでものすごい神経使って料理作るのかと
肉体に対する愛着なんですね
そういうところは見えてくるんです
それで食べる瞑想は 終了です
あと 今日のご指導ではちょっと省略されてたんですけど
食べる瞑想の時には食べる瞑想の前の言葉がありますよね
うん あれはやっぱり唱えた方がよろしいですか？ まあまあ
食べることが瞑想であるならば
別に唱えなくてもいいのです
時々瞑想しないで 普通のいろんな修行
いろんなことをやっている場合でも食べますから
これは必ず前に唱えるようなしているんで
忘れないように 食べること自体が瞑想になっているんだから
別になくたってもよろしいと
大体ない方がいいと思いますね
むしろむしろ  瞑想としてやる場合は
初めからする瞑想  初めれば
この肉体を修復するためにいただきますと言っちゃうと
なんかちょっと合わないんですね
瞑想と それはまあ普通食べる時のアプローチであって
瞑想する人は食べるということをやっていないんです
伸ばす 取る 運ぶ 噛む 味わうということをやっているんだからね
はい それからあの長い時間
瞑想を実践して 心清らかになるまで頑張る
次のレッスン 3つを説明します
レッスン 6 7 8 で まず覚えておいてください
あの 簡単です 立つ 歩く
座る ３つもいっぺんに理解できます
で 今まで悟りに達した方々は
誰でもこの立つ 歩く 座るという 3つの瞑想で成功したんですね
だからといって他の瞑想をやらないと意味がないんだけどね
最後にこれになるんですね
そこでこの瞑想っていうのは
そんなに難しくもなく
いつでもできるし 何時間でもできますね
で この生きるってどういうことかと科学的に見てみること
神秘的にでも宗教的でもストーリー的
神話的でも見ないで ただ自分の体を見てみる
体が生きているんだからね
その体が何をやっているのかと
主に体は動いているんだよ
動くの場合は 動きの場合は
重く切っちゃうと歩く
立つ 座る 横になるっていうのは基本的な行為 4
つあるんです これはどんな生命もやっているんです
歩く 立つ 横に座る 横になる
言ったら ヘビはどうやって横になるのかどうかね
座るのかどうか聞かないでください
私に聞いたって 私はヘビじゃないんだから
我々知っている生命はね
仲良しで 生命はだいたいそれ 4つやっていますね
その中で横になることを瞑想にしちゃうとまずいんです
なぜかというと 横になるのは寝るためなんですね
だから決まっているんですね
横になると何するのかと
ですから 寝ることは瞑想じゃないんですね
寝ること 瞑想だったら
人類は全ての生命はもう悟っているでしょうね
人間より先に猫が悟っているでしょうね
だから寝ることは瞑想じゃないんです
寝ることが仏教ではあまり推薦しない
なぜならば 寝る間で脳開発は難しいんですね
脳は自分で決まったプログラムで動いているだけで
外のデータも何も受け入れないんですね
だからアイドリング状態で動いているんだけど
車 アイドリング状態で何もやってないんですね
だからアイドリング状態の車っていうのは
やっぱり使い物にならないね
これ ギア入れないとクラッチを入れないと
うん で ですから残るのは歩く
立つ 座る そこに実況中継入れてみる
それだけ で 座る瞑想でまたもうちょっと詳しく説明します
まず あの立つ瞑想を説明しましょう
立つ瞑想っていうのは至ってシンプルで立つことです
何のこともないんです
立つというこの行為はどのように成り立っているのかと
コマ動きでチェックしてみるんです
だから立つ場合は体崩さなくちゃいけないんですね
今座っていると仮定しましょう
座っている人が立てなくちゃいけない
それで立つ瞑想にする
はい それで今私も座っていますね
私が立つ場合は 私には残念ながら足 2本あるんですね
だからすぐこう両方足いっぺんに使いたくなっちゃうんです
これって怠けなんです
そうではなくて 一個ずつ一個ずつ動かして
すごく伸ばしてスローで立ってみるんです
例えば今の座り方から見れば
左足を先に動かす動かしやすいですから
左足上げる 上げる 上げる
上げる 上げる 立てる 立てる
立てる 立てる こんな程度に立てたらなんかまずいように感じるんだから
そこでストップする で
手がこのよりは かすった方がいいんですね
ですから 右手を伸ばす
伸ばす 伸ばす 置く 置く
置く 左手上げる 上げる
置く 年寄りの私はちょっと手に力入れなくちゃいけないんですね
力入れる で 右足上げる
上げる 上げる 上げる 上げる
立てる それから腰を上げる
上げる 上げる 上げる 前に体を移動させる
移動させる で これはあくまでもスマナサーラという年寄りの立ち方で
皆様は真似する必要ない
皆さんは皆様のやり方でやってください
どうする？それから で
胴体を上げなくちゃいけないんですね
で 上げる 上げる 上げる
上げる 上げる 上げる 上げる
上げる 胴体上げる ですね
で 立ったら両足もこういう風にあるんですね
それでこういう実況中継するんです
右足広げる 広げる 広げる
左足広げる 広げる 広げる
それで肩幅程度に両足を広げるんです
それからテレビ カメラで見えないことがあるんです
こういう風に言って 均等になる
均等になる 均等になる
均等になると実況するんです
実況しながら体均等になるまで待つんです
均等になる 均等になる
均等になると言いながら
左足と右足とかちょっと感じてみるんです
こういう風に振ることはしません
振らない代わりに均等になる
均等になる 均等になる
均等になる 均等になると実況中継すると
体が自分勝手に均等になってくれるんです
均等になったら次 運ぶ
運ぶ 運ぶ 運ぶ 運ぶ 運ぶ
運ぶ 結ぶ 結ぶ 結ぶ 両手をこういう風に結んじゃうんです
次 背筋を伸ばすんです
背筋を伸ばす場合はお尻で伸ばすんです
はい お尻にちょっぴり力を入れて伸ばす
伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす
伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばすと
で 背筋を伸ばすんです
そこを伸ばしたら柱になるのです
いわゆる １ミリも動かないでこういう風にいるんです
柱になってから下半身感じるんです
下半身を感じて立ってます
感じています 立っています
感じています と実況中継するんです
この立つ瞑想はだいたい 10 分
10 分  15 分ぐらいやってほしい
それで適当にまず足をこうやってちゃんと広げることをやってください
するとちゃんとバランスを整えてよく立っていられることができるんです
ちょっと時間経つと このたつという働きがわかってくるんですね
体の感覚が仕事をして
仕事をして立たせてくれるんだなと
だから立つということでも
一個の仕事ではなく ずっと連続して多数出す
たすたす立つってことしなくちゃいけないんです
神経が絶えず仕事をしなくちゃいけないんです
感覚が絶えず変化していかなくちゃいけないんです
だけど ただ見た目はそうじゃない
ただ柱のように立ってるだけ
立ってます 感じています
立っています 感じています
立っています 感じているのは立っています
感じています 立っています
感じていますと そうやって言っているだけなんですが
中がすごい工場のように働いているんですね
それをチェックしてください
大体 10 分 15 分あたりで十分です
長い時間立つ必要はないんです
はい それが私の瞑想です
では 7番目の歩く瞑想をこれから説明します
歩く瞑想をする人々はどうせ立てなくちゃいけないですね
こういうふうにちゃんとしっかり立つんです
立って実況中継で手を運ぶ
運ぶ 運ぶ 結ぶ 結ぶと結びます
後ろにもそれでもいいので
運ぶ 運ぶ 運ぶ 結ぶ 結ぶ
結ぶと そして自然に手を運んで結ぶんですよ
それから背筋を伸ばすんです
伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす 次のポイントは胴体を固定してもらう
下半身２本の足だけ動かせてもらう
で 日本の脚だけ動かして歩く瞑想してみます
ここから始まります こういう風に立って胴体を固定して実況します
歩きます 右足上げます
運びます 降ろします 左足あげます
運びます 下ろします 右足上げます
運びます 下ろします 左足挙げます
運びます 下ろします 止まります
回ります 右足回します
左足回します 右足回します
左足回します 止まります
歩きます 右足上げます
運びます 下ろします 左足上げます
運びます 下ろします 右足上げます
運びます 下ろします 止まります
回ります 左足回します
右足回します 左足回します
右足回します 止まります
歩きます 左足上げます
運びます 下ろします 右足上げます
運びます 下ろします 左足上げます
運びます 下ろします 止まります
回ります 左右や右足回します
左足回します 右足回します
左足回します 止まります
歩きます 右足上げます
運びます 下ろします 左足上げます
運びます 下ろします 右足上げます
運びます 下ろします はい
そういう感じで あの ある程度の畳二帖くらいの三畳くらいでも距離を考えて行ったり来たり
行ったり来たり 行ったり来たりしてください
自分好きな幅でよろしいんです
自分好きなスピードでも構いません
この瞑想はちょっと問題がありまして
1時間やらなくちゃいけないんです
5分 10 分では何の意味もないんです
だからこの空調の世界
ただ物体がリズミカルに動いているだけのこと
そこもあらゆる因果法則によって成り立っていることをわかるまで
やらなくちゃいけない
だから 1時間やってほしい 1
時間やると最後の二 三分でちょこちょこっと心が成長するんです
結構失敗もしますけど
構いません まあ何回も繰り返してやってみてください
それから 座る瞑想に入る前に
座る瞑想はより厳しいんです
座る瞑想に入る前に この瞑想
歩く瞑想 何回も繰り返して繰り返して繰り返して 1
時間 1時間 1時間 何回でもいいんだけど
何日でもいいんだ 例えば 1週間でもいいんです
決めて歩く瞑想ばっかりやってやってみてください
で それでものすごい効果な効果がある瞑想だと仏典でも語られているんです
歩く瞑想は 効果な瞑想っていうのは効き目がある
瞑想っていうのは やっぱりこのまず体の調子が良くなる
左右のバランスが良くなる
それから集中力がものすごく出てくる
それから周りが雑音あっても
いろんなことがあっても
それに誘惑されないで自分のことをできる人間になってくるんです
だからよくあることですね
修行する人は山に隠れるとかね
道場に隠れるとかね 道場に隠れたっても
無知な人は無知なんですね
やらない人はやらないんですね
だからこの場所ではダメ
あの場所でダメっていう風な世間に指差す人は何も得られないんです
だから商店街であっても
歩く瞑想はできる人にできますよ
だから周りいくら物事あっても誘惑されないような安穏な心でいる
例えば商店街で歩く瞑想するならばね
普通にこうやって普通に歩けばいいんです
別に 左足 左足 右足 左足
右足で 周りは関係なく
はい そういう風に歩く瞑想をやってみてください
これは瞑想の大体セントラルポイントなんですね
瞑想は大事 歩く瞑想を中心に回っているんです
はい 説明は以上です はい
それでは最後のレッスン
座る瞑想 で だいたい世の中で瞑想とは座っていることと思ってますけど
ヴィパッサナー世界ではそうじゃないんです
自己観察が瞑想なんです
だから 一番最初にものを動かすところからも
正真正銘の瞑想をやっていたんです
ただ やりやすいところからどんどん難しいところまで進むだけ
難しいっていうのは 集中力が必要し
忍耐力が必要になるし
もうそれだけのことなんですね
だから結構集中力 忍耐力は座る瞑想には必要なんですね
座る瞑想こそ王様が天皇陛下ではないんです
まあどちらでも平等で瞑想なんですね
でもある程度で座る瞑想もしなくちゃいけない
バランスを整って 歩く瞑想と座る瞑想
両方しなくちゃいけないんです
座る瞑想の時間っていうのは
初心者は30分やってほしい
で 30分も難しいならば
まず歩く瞑想を繰り返し繰り返しやったら
座る瞑想できるように体が
調整します それで三十分は座れるようになります
はい これは基本的なところ
では 座る瞑想の順番で説明していきます
座る瞑想の場合は動かないんですね
しかし 動かないんだけど
体は動いて動いているんです
歩く立つみたいな動きはないんだけど
体が動いているんです
体が動いているっていうことは
細胞たちが伸びたり縮んだり
伸びたり縮んだり 伸びたり縮んだり
これ 生まれた瞬間からお腹の中で生まれた瞬間から起きている出来事なんです
お腹に最初に生命が現れた時
細胞一個だけ その一個の細胞も伸び縮み
伸び縮みやっているんです
だから生きているかない
死んでいるかっていうチェックする方法っていうのは
動いているかないかなんです
なんで動くのかというと
なんか苦しみがあるんです
だから動かずにいられないんです
だから苦しみを生命を生かしているんです
はい ですから 座る瞑想をする前に
このレッスン ちょっとレッスンなりまでやります
第一 ストップモーションというんです
ストップモーションというのは
体が置き物のように止めてみること
立っているよりは座っている時
それやりやすいんですね
しっかり座って できる範囲で背筋を伸ばして
目も閉じてストップモーションするんです
こういう風に  ほんのちょっと皆様に見せます
はい このようにストップモーション
置き物のように体を止めておく
これ ちょっと難しいんです
だからもう一つ裏技があるんです
で こうやって体を止めてから
体止めてやる 止めてやるという気持ちではなく
体の感覚を感じて放っておきます
なんでストップモーションするのかとさせるのかというと
難しいでしょという納得のためなんです
動いた方が楽でしょ 動かないと苦しいでしょという合意に達してほしいんです
だからストップして こういう風に
これいかに大変難しいのかと理解してください
その目的です そこで それでもやらなくちゃいかんでしょ
裏技があるんです こうやって座っていて
足の裏から頭のてっぺんまでの感覚を感じて放っておくんです
こういう風に 見えませんよ
感覚を感じるということは
こういう風に感覚を感じて放っておく
感覚を感じる場合は この座っている姿をね
イメージで出てきて 誰にだって脳の中でマップがありますからね
体のボディマップがあるんですよ
だから座っているボディマップが脳の中に現れるんですね
このボディマップの中で感覚がある
感覚を感じて気にしないことにする
反応しないことにする
生きることは感覚に反応することです
痛くなったらすぐ崩れる
足を崩す 痒くなったらかく
お腹が空いたっていうのは感覚ですよ
お腹が感覚出たら食べる
喉が渇いたっていうのは感覚ですよ
飲む だから感覚が出るたびに反応するんですよ
誰だって犬猫でも これがただのどんな生命の生き方なんです
ちょいとした生き方じゃないんです
そこで こちらでは一切生命が感覚に反応する
痒くなったらかく 痛くなったら体くすぐる
あるいは怪我などの痛みだったら
人間だったら手当てをする
反応するんです ウイルスに感染したら体が反応する
だから命はそういうこと
感覚に反応する ウイルスの場合は感覚反応できなかったら死にます
はい それで今度は なんで感覚に反応するのかと
感覚そのものがあんまり面白くないんです
例えば かゆみって超面白い？足が痛くなったらすごく面白い？足がしびれたら？どんな感覚も気持ち悪い感覚なんですよ
いつでもこの感覚が早く終わってほしいと思っているんです
だから反応したらすぐ変わるんですよ
人間それ理解していないんです
人間っていうのは 生命っていうのは
この感覚を変えて 変えて
変えて 変えて 変えて変えまくっちゃうんです
いくら変えても新たな感覚が生まれる A
という感覚を変えたら B
という感覚になる Bという感覚は気持ち悪いんだから C
という感覚に変える C
という感覚は気持ち悪いんだだからDという感覚に変える D
という感覚は気持ち悪いんだから A
という感覚に変える A
という感覚は気持ち悪いんだから B
という感覚に変える それでサイクルが出来上がっちゃうんです
本当はABCDではなくてABCだけ 3
つです Aの感覚からBの感覚 B
の感覚からCの感覚 C
の感覚からAの感覚 だから感覚は3つです
ドゥッカ スッカ ドゥッカ
ウペッカーというパーリ語でね
苦 楽 不苦不楽という を回転していく
どこまでやるのかと だから輪廻転生を無限に起こるんです
ここで我々は生命の法則を破ってみるんです
こうやって座っていると
右膝には痛みがあるんですね
放っておく 足を崩さない
なんか背中に痒みがありますね
まあいいや 放っておく
なんか左足がなんかしびれたような感じが
放っておきますという感じで放っておくんです
そこを2 3分やってみてください
ストップモーション 感覚を感じて放っておく
そこでパスワードが現れます
放っておく この放っておくことは
宇宙全体の生命法則に対する違うこと
この法則を破ることなんです
すべての生命が神々であろうか
地獄の生命であろうか
悪魔と悪魔のグループであろうか
誰だって感覚に反応するんです
それで輪廻転生しているんです
智慧のある人は感覚に反応しないっていうことにいるんです
かゆみが出たら放っておくんです
かゆくなっ 痛くなったら放っておくんです
だから精進しないとね
心が強くないとできないんですね
そこら辺はレッスンで出てきます
そこでこの放っておくことは
無執着というレベルまで上がるんです
無執着になったら悟っているんです
だから悟りの秘密 悟りの鍵
悟りのパスワードは放っておくことなんです
はい その2つ やってみましょう
で 次にあの 瞑想には入ってみる
瞑想に入ってみることは
こういうふうに座って体を固定して感覚を感じて放っておく
それから実況中継します
座ってます 感じています
座ってます 感じていますと頭で実況してください
はい では順番に言います
まず 1 分ぐらい体ストップして感じてみてください
1 分  2 分ぐらい だいたい私の個人的な判断では
まあ 3 分ぐらい時間時計回して 3 分ぐらい止めておく
それからもう大変だ これはとわかるんですね
それでもう一度 3 分つけて
感覚を感じて放っておく
放っておく これはこの痛み放っておくと
また 3 分やってみる それ終わったらもう一度 3 分実況中継もする
感覚を感じて放っておいて
それは実況しない それから座ってます
感じています 座ってます
感じていますと このストップモーションやってみてください
そうすると 3 かける 3 は 9 9 分になりますね
それが座る瞑想に必要な準備です
それで知恵で言えば 体がずっと伸びたり縮み
伸び縮み 伸び縮み 伸び縮みやってるんです
歩いたっても伸び縮み
走ったっても伸び縮み
寝ても伸び縮み 細胞には他の動きはできません
回転する細胞ないでしょ？でも我々には体回転することできますね
でも細胞は回転しませんよ
細胞は伸び縮みだけ はい
なんで伸び縮みがあるのかというと
この細胞一個一個の中に感じられるという
感じられるという能力があるんです
アビリティがあるんです
センシティビティという英語で言えばあるんです
このセンシティビティ
感受性っていうのは命なんです
命の定義は仏教ではそういうふうにあるんです
パーリ語ではサンニャーですね
サニーと言うんで その場合は
サニーっていうのは命があるっていうことで
センシティセンシティビティ
感あまり英語日本語にならんですね
感じられる能力 感受性という単語もありますけどね
だから物質に感受性があるんです
命です それで感じることをありがたいというとありがたくないね
だから動くんです もっといい感覚ないの？もっといい感覚ないのと下がっているんです
すべての生命は赤ちゃんからもっといい感覚ないのと下がっているんです
それが生きることなんです
ということは あなた 今の感覚
気持ち悪いでしょ？なんです
それでいい感覚 赤ちゃん
子供だったら走ったり
なんとかなんとかやったりして
でもすぐそれをやめて別な感覚に行くんです
子供の場合 よくあるでしょ
1 分  2 分もじっとしていられないんですね
何かやる それやめてまた何かやる
子供も一緒 でももっといい感覚ないの？もっといい感覚ないのと死ぬまで下がっているんです
ということは いつだって現在感覚では満足していないんです
ということは 一生満足する感覚を感じたことはないんです
ということは 生きることは不安であって苦しみなんです
それは真理第1すぐ経験できます
ストップモーションやってみてください
ストップモーションの瞑想は
まあ例えば続けて 15 分ぐらいやってみたら
ものの見事に生きることは空であるとわかるんです
だからそれに執着する
吾輩はなんとしてでも 200 歳まで生きてやるぞと思う？思わないです
苦しみたいというインタープリテーションですよ
翻訳すると生きていきたいとは苦しみたいって意味なんです
それは経験した人は悟りに達します
頭でわかっても悟りに達しません
はい 説明は長すぎ はい
それ終わったら本格的に座る瞑想に入ります
座る瞑想の場合は まず座り方
ちょこちょこと説明します
あまり難しい ちょっとお尻をちょっと高い位置にするんですね
まあ例えばまあ今私はこういう風に座布団使ってますね
もうこの座布団の高さ
まあこれぐらいでも十分ですけど
あるいは何かモデルサンプルないんですかね
腰掛けの まあ例えば座布団
禅寺でやっているこういうものもあるし
まあこれ高いものの場合
これはちょっと薄すぎですけどね
これもあるし またテーラワーダ協会でこういうものも作ってあるんですね
これはちょっと硬いんだけど
これに座ったらちょっと高い位置になるんですね
その方が楽に座れるんです
それで座る場合はお尻全部ではなくて
座骨で座るんです で カメラで見えませんだけど
私は座布団のほんのちょっとで座っているんです
座布団そのまま 座骨で座るんですよ
座骨で座って で ちょっと骨盤前に骨盤だけ前にこういう風に倒しておくんです
倒してから座骨で座布団につけて置いておくんです
足は自分の好きなように合わせてください
組める方 組んでください
組めない方々は合わせてください
しかし 膝が床に触れる必要があるんですよ
で 膝がこういう風に上がっちゃうとすごく苦しくなるんです
今言ってるのは長い時間少ない苦しみで座る方法なんです
はい それ終わったら手も置いて
まず 背筋を伸ばす 実況中継でお尻から伸ばす
伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす
伸ばす 背筋をまっすぐ伸ばす
伸ばしてから背中に頑丈な板を張っているような気分になってください
背中に頑丈な板を張っていて
こんな感じでこうならない
こういう風に板を張ったような感じになってから
ちょっと胴体を倒してみます
ドカンと倒す こんな感じで倒してみるんです
これは2 3回やってみた方がよろしいと思います
倒す で 次 胴体をこういう風に倒す
倒してから実況します
目を胴体倒しても首がまっすぐ
背中がまっすぐ 目を閉じます
閉じます 閉じます 閉じます
閉じます 閉じます 閉じますと
お尻の方がちょっと痛くなるまでやるんです
目を閉じます 閉じます
閉じます それでお尻の方がちょっと胴体の重さが感じるんです
感じたらこのままゆっくり超スローモーションで上げる
上げる 上げる 上げる 上げる
止める 固定します 固定します
固定します と固定します
止めるというのは ちょうどいいところに来たら固定します
止めます 止めて固定します
目は閉じたままに 固定しますと言った瞬間からストップモーションです
全く動かないんです 今私喋ってますから動いてますけど
こうやって固定しますと言ったら終わり
動かない 置物 次 深呼吸するんです
背中に板張ってるんですよ
だからどうやって深呼吸するんですかね
やり方があるんです このお腹の辺り
風船のようにするんです
おへその周り 風船のように風船膨らませちゃう
風船を縮める 縮む そんな感じでやるんです
それで実況中 深呼吸 実況中継はやりますので
実況しながら吸います
吸います 吸い実況すると吐き出しなるんですね
なんか変ですね はい これで私は 2回深呼吸したんです
結構時間かかったね  2回いっぱい吸って全部吐き出しちゃったんです
だから体はちゃんと固定して背筋を伸ばしてるんだから
結構ゆっくり吸います
吸います 吸います 吸います
とお腹をずっと膨らませて
体は動かないんですよ
ここら辺動いたっても衣に隠れていてお腹見えない
で 吐きます 吐きます とこうやってもう全部吐き出しているのに体動かないんです
そうやって皆様のマンダリンの言葉では腹式呼吸というね
ことになるんです お腹は膨らまして縮まして
お腹風船です という感じで深呼吸をするんです
だいたい私には 2回もあれぐらい時間かかったんだから
3回  4回行ったらちょっと時間がかかりますよ
3回  4回程度でやってから深呼吸をやめて
このままで体を動かさないで
待ちます 待ちます 待ちます
待ちます 待ちますと実況する
それで感じるんです 膝
お尻 足 背中 お腹 首 頭 感じるんです
待ちます 待ちます 待ちます
待ちます 待ちます 次にお腹を感じるんです
実況は待ちます 待ちます
待ちます 待ちます 待ちます
待ちます そこでお腹の中に膨らみ縮みがあると見えてくるんです
風船の経験もありますからね
おへそ辺りでなんか膨らんだり縮んだりするんです
それで自分が何もやらない気持ちで待ちますっていうのはそういう意味なんです
あんた待ちなさい 何もやるなよと
ただ置物のように待ちなさい
それで命をチェックしなさいと
置物になってみたら お腹が膨らんだり縮んだりする
それ第三人称で実況します
膨らみ 膨らみ 縮み 縮み
そこで膨らんで膨らみ始めると
膨らみ 膨らみ 膨らみ 縮み始めると縮み
縮み 縮み 縮み 膨らみが長いんだったら
膨らみ 膨らみ 膨らみ 膨らみ
膨らみ 縮み 縮み 縮み 縮み
縮み 縮み 短いんだったら膨らみ
縮み 膨らみ 縮み そんなのはどうでもいい
自分には関係ないんです
自分が何もやってない
待ちます 自分がウェイティングというモードにいるんです
ウェイティング 待ってるだけ
お腹やってることにはもうどうとも責任はないんです
だから膨らみ 縮み 膨らみ
縮み 短いんだったら 長いんだったら膨らみ
膨らみ 膨らみ 縮み 縮み
縮み 縮み 実況してみてください
時々お腹っていろんなことやりますよ
膨らみ 膨らみと待っちゃうんですね
それからだって言ってください
膨らみ 膨らみ 止まってる
止まってる 縮み 縮み 縮み
縮み 止まってる 止まってる
膨らみ 膨らみ 膨らみ 止まってるとか
止まってないんだったらそれでいいんです
もう無責任状態で修行者は責任持たない
待ちます ウェイティングというモードでいるんです
そこで生まれて初めて肉体を客観的に見られます
そこを覚えておいてください
膨らみます 縮みますという単語を絶対使わないでください
第一人称になっちゃうんです
そこで新たな問題が出てくる
あの今まで止めていた
この妄想の世界 捏造の世界
幻覚の世界 まだまだありますからね
保管して でたらめの記憶としてインチキ記憶倉庫まだあるんです
だから膨らみ縮み膨らみ縮み入っていると雑念が割り込むんです
割り込んだ途端  3回妄想
妄想 妄想と言ってから膨らみ縮み
ちょっと実際やります
そこで膨らみ縮み 膨らみ縮み
膨らみ縮み 妄想 妄想 妄想
膨らみ縮み 膨らみ縮み
妄想出たら出てできなかったら膨らみ縮み
そこですぐやってください
妄想すぐ潰してください
それでストップモーションモードでいるんです
置物モードで これで 2 3 分
4 分  5 分経つと痛みが出てくるんですよ
いくら正しく座っても
肉体には痛みは本来の感覚だから出ます
だけど どこかが痛くなったら放っておくんです
例えばここら辺痛くなったとしましょう
この右膝の方で膨らみ縮み
膨らみ縮み 膨らみ縮み
痛くなってきましたね
そこで痛み 痛み 痛み 痛み
痛み 痛み 痛み 痛み 痛みと実況するんです
まあ別にそれぐらい痛みだと思ったら
膨らみ縮み 膨らみ縮み
膨らみ縮みというんです
またやっぱり痛みが気になるんだったら
痛み 痛み 痛みというんです
その時でも 痛み 痛み 痛みで雑念割り込むね
雑念割り込んだら妄想
妄想 妄想 痛み 痛み 痛み
痛み 痛みが終わったら膨らみ縮み膨らみ縮み
危険なのは妄想です こういう風にすると痛みはできますね
それで膨らみ縮み膨らみ縮み
なんか背中の方で痒くなってくるんですね
あるいはほっぺたの方で痒くなってくるんです
私の場合はどうしてもほっぺたの方が痒くなるんですね
だって痒いやすいんだからね
痒くなったら何のことなく
かゆみ かゆみ かゆみ かゆみ
放っておくということは
キーワードかゆみ かゆみ
かゆみ かゆみ 雑念始まる
妄想 妄想 妄想 痒み 痒み
痒み 痒み 痒み 膨らみ 縮み
膨らみ 縮み 膨らみ 縮み
膨らみ 縮み 膨らむ 縮み
また痒くなったら痒み
痒み 痒み 気にしないでください
痒みが皆様を脅す場合もありますよ
痛みは我慢できるんだけど
痒みは我慢できないんです
イライラするんで 脅しです
悪魔の気にはしない それで痒みは動くんです
例えばここら辺 痒くなっちゃって
ジリジリジリジリそういう風になってくるんですね
怖くなります え？虫でも入ってるんじゃないかなと
アウト 痒みが動いたら別に痒み
痒み 痒み 痒みとか そう言ってやればいいんです
動いてるところも動いている
動いている 痒みが動いている
自分が実況するだけ 怖くなったらあかん
そこでしびれたらしびれしびれと言ってください
暖かくなったら大体2 3回繰り返して瞑想すると暖かくなったりもします
暖かくなっている 仏教用語だったらターポーと言うんですけど
熱 熱を感じている 熱を感じている
だから冷えたらもう熱なんです
え？冷えても熱なんです
だから熱が内向きだったら暖かいというんです
熱が外向きだったら冷えていう
冷えて冷えているというんです
矢印の方向なんです もともとは熱なんです
熱が入ると暖かいというね
出ていくと冷えているというんです
だから冷えていると感じたら冷や系感
冷え 冷えている 冷えている
冷えている 寒いと言わないでください
第一印象 暑いと言わないでください
第一印象 熱を感じている
熱を感じている 日焼けを感じている
どちらでもさすがに割り込んだら妄想
妄想 それは先に処分するんです
妄想は自分が作った化け物ですからね
熱やら日焼けやら 自分が作ったものじゃないんです
これは宇宙法則です それは観察するんです
実況中継するんです そうやっていると
時々何か体が軽くなったり感じるんです
なんか軽くなって 軽くなっている
軽く感じている 軽く感じている
それはこの地水火風の風の幻想に心が行っちゃうと軽く感じるんです
これは自己コントロールできないんです
心は勝手に勝手に負の幻想をチェックしちゃうと
体が軽く感じるんです
時々体がもう今の体重よりは10 20倍 20
倍ではなくて 2倍3倍重く感じるんです 20
倍感じません なんか体重が2倍になったんじゃないか
重く感じるんです あれは心が土の幻想を認識しているんです
パタウィを認識しているんです
その時は私たちはパタウィかどうかわからんだからね
地水火風かどっちかわからんだから
重く感じていると実況してください
硬く感じていると実況してください
時々な体がぐにゃぐにゃぐにゃぐにゃするように感じる場合もあります
しかし 一瞬妄想でよ じーっと止まっていなくちゃあかんです
じっと止まっているんだけど
なんか体がぐにゃぐにゃ
なんか動くように あれは風の幻想なんです
だから心はわがままで風を認識しているんです
そうすると修行者がなんか体が波打っているようにと感じるんです
そうすると なんとなくその適切な言葉でゆらゆらしているとかね
揺らぎを感じている なんとか言ってください
で そんな風に起こる出来事を全部実況中継してください
大体30分ぐらい で 30
分ぐらい終わってから
瞑想は座る 瞑想を終了するんです
瞑想の終了は悟ってからなんです
座る 瞑想を終了するんです
深呼吸をするんです 吸います
吸います 吸います 吸います
吸います 吐きます 吐きます
吐きます 吐きます 終わります
吸います 吸います 吸います
吸います 吸います 吐きます
吐きます 吐きます 吐きます
終わります 吸います 吸います
吸います 吸います 吐きます
吐きます 吐きます 吐きます
終わります 目を開けます
開けます 開けますと終わるんです
座る 瞑想終わった それからまた瞑想が始まりますよ
別に足を上げる 上げる
上げる 立てる立てる 腰を上げる
立てればいいんです 立てばいいんです
立ってからちょっと5分ぐらい立っていて
立ってます 感じています
それから歩く瞑想に行くんです
歩く瞑想は1時間 そういうサイクルでいくらでも 1 日でも瞑想はできるんです
その間でご飯食べるは
トイレに行くはお茶飲むはそれもやります
全部瞑想中 修行中 すべて実況中継でやるんです
そういうことで瞑想のフルバージョンになります
で 上達したら智慧の世界が現れてくると
個人的なアドバイスをする必要ある場合もない場合もあります
誰だって最初に物体 物体と感覚というのは明確にわかるんです
命っていうのは物体があって
感覚機能があるんだと
感じる機能があるんだと
これは名色分離智慧というんです
その人には吾輩は生きているんだということは消えているんです
だから なんだこれ 物体に感覚あるだけでしょうと
だからそこで誤解しない
あ 俺が悟ったと だって自我で見てないんだから
それは第一ステップで名色分離智慧なんですね
これ智慧なんです さらに同じく実況中継しなくちゃいけないんです
それで実況中継すると
物質は物質の勝手に因果法則で動いていることを見えてくるんです
感覚は感覚の勝手で 因果法則で動いてくる動いていることは見えてくるんです
それから物質と感覚が合体して勝手な因果法則で動いてくることは見えてくるんです
すると ただの因果法則でやっていることで
なんだこりゃと お手上げやという感じになるんです
誰かがやっていることじゃないんだと
例えば 足がじーっとこうやって組んでいると
ここで物質 物質が合って圧力かかっちゃって
感覚が痛く感じるんです
それだけ それで圧力は減っちゃうと痛みは減っていく
なんだこれ それぞれの因果法則やとわかると
次のステージの智慧なんです
これは何て言いますか
えーと カンカーアビタラナというんですけどね
まああまり一般的に私は説明しないんですからね
あの で カンカー疑惑がなくなるということは
真理はすべて因縁によって成り立つものであって
一切の物事は大宇宙であろうが生命であろうが
それが真理で だから世にあるすべての哲学は嘘です
それ発見してないとやっぱり疑いがあるんですね
まるまるさんが言っていることも一理あり
この人が言っていることにも一理あり
神様はいると言っているんだから
もしかするといるかも
神の名前あの連中アッラーと言うんだから
もしかすると神のアッラーかも
まあイエホワと言んだから
もしかぎばっかしなんです
すべて消えます 宇宙はいつ始めただろうとかね
関係ない 因果法則です
ビッグバンの前どうなったのかと
因果法則で調べれば だから因果法則やと分かった人には何の義務もないんです
そうすると 私の疑いが消えちゃったんだから
ブッダの教えは真理だとわかったんだから
やっぱり悟ったと勘違いしないでください
それはそれからなんです
でも因 よるかの条件もどんどんどんどん現れてくるんです
はい そこは智慧のステージはこの 2つを止めます
それからあの すごい集中力で瞑想すると
膨らみ縮み膨らみ縮みといっても
現れては消える 現れては消える
現れては消える 痛み 痛み
痛み 痛みが現れて消える
現れて消える 痛みではなく
痛みのチェーンなんです
丸い痛みじゃないんです
例えば膝のところ痛くなってる
これ痛みのチェーンなんです
痛み 痛み 痛み 痛み 痛み
痛み 痛み 痛みと 膨らみといっても膨らみではなくて
膨らみ 膨らみ 膨らみ 膨らみ
膨らみでチェーンでなんですね
で そうやって 刻々とっていうんですかね
見えてくるんです 膨らみといっても
もうちっちゃなちっちゃなちっちゃなちっちゃな膨らみがだらだらだらだら溶けてて
恐ろしい速さで溶けているんです
痛みといっても 恐ろしい痛み
痛み 痛みの波が生まれているんです
波といっても 我々は紙で描く波じゃないんです
点で波を描かなくちゃかんです
点点点点点点点点 だからそれは生滅智慧というんです
だから生じて滅する 生じて滅する
生じて滅すると その時はあまり言葉を使えなくなる
あまりにも早いんだからね
だから普通に膨らみ縮み膨らみ縮みで
まあ状態を保った方がいいんですね
まあそれでまあじわじわと悟りには達します
で 悟りに達したっていうことは
もうもうこれは個人的にわかるあれば違うんだから
まああまり公の瞑想レッスンではちょっと言いづらいんですね
まあ自我がないっていうことは明確にわかる
やっぱり自我がないんだとわかったらね
体験で私はいないんだと
昔も今もこれからも これ
体験でわかったことは悟りの境地なんですね
頭でわかることは大したことはないね
そのうち忘れますからね
すぐ自我がありますからね
あるいはネズソをわかった人
あ 頭の中でもうストーリー作って
作って 作って作って 幻覚にいるんだと
え？今まで幻覚にいたんだからと
なんだこりゃと 幻覚そこらへんとという納得にいったら
それもよるから悟りない
だから個人差がありますね
はい そういうことで瞑想を行って頑張って幸福になってみてください
幸せにはなります 悟りに達しなくたっても
能力が向上して すごく明るく生きられて
心には罪がなくて 悪がなくて
いつでも善の心でいられて
ものすごい楽しく生活できるんです
瞑想はうまくいかなくたっても
死後は天国には行きます
もう無理にでも地獄に落とすことはできません
そういうわけで どう見ても副作用のない瞑想なので
ブッダの瞑想を頑張って皆様幸福になっていただきたいと思います
ありがとうございます
えっと さっきのあのえっと
待ちます 待ちますっていう時は呼吸とかは普通にしてても大丈夫なんです
呼吸は気にしないんですね
うん 呼吸は放っておくといいました
呼吸は放っておく  呼吸を放っておいて
待ちます 待ちます 待ちます
だから言ったで 深呼吸やめて
待ちます 待ちます  深呼吸を止めてやめて
息を止めているわけじゃないですね
深呼吸止めるだけ うん
あの窒息しちゃう人が出てきそうな
それからあの 先ほどその寝るべ
あのね 寝ることは瞑想にならないって話だったんですけど
最近やっぱりそのコロナウイルスが流行ったりして
まあ寝込む人は結構多いと思うんですけど
日常の中で寝こ 寝込まざるを得ない人は多いと思うんですけど
寝込まざるを得ない人はどういう風に瞑想すればよろしいですか
普段瞑想する経験がある人にはできるんだけどね
しっかりと瞑想できる人なら
どうしても横にならなくちゃいけない場合でも瞑想はできます
その時でも感覚を実況するだけ
だから横になったらもう感覚はいろんなものなっちゃうんだから
面倒くさいんですね だから一つ選ぶ
例えば足は感じるわ お尻を感じるわ
背中を感じるわ 首を感じるわ
だからもうもうバラバラ
いろんなものを感じちゃうんですね
いち面倒くさい だから一つ選んで
その感覚を実況中継するんです
でお腹感じてるんだったら膨らんでる
縮んでるし あるいは呼吸を感じてるんだったら
吸ってる 吐いてる 吸ってる
吐いてると実況すればいいんです
サッビートゥワジャンツーサッバローゴウィナッセットマテーパワートワンタラーヨスティービーガーユコパワバウトサッブマンガランラッカントサッブデバタサッブブ
ッダヌバーヴェーナサッブダッマヌバーヴェーナサッブサンガーヌバーヴェーナサダスティーバヴァントゥテーアビワダナシーリーシャニッチャンバッダパチャイノチ
ャッターローダンマヴァッダムティーアイワンノースカンバランあゆらーロギャサンパッティサッガサンパッティメーヴェチャアトーニンバーナサンパッティエミナテーサミンジャトゥ
カーンティーパラマントポーティティックカーニッバーナナンパラマンワダンキーブッダ